who said
who said feminists can't be funny
incidentally I don't know why the lights
aren't on for the audience this is a
town meeting after all the idea of that
and I think lights should be on you as
well as on us since you're part of it so
I'll be Claudius and Hamlet lights no
lights he didn't do it I'll be himself
let there be life not could we have
lights um no I think would be a hell of
a good idea because then you're part of
it cuz that's what this is about
that's the ticket
more that's it it should be lit more you
we should see your faces as well as
you're seeing ours fair is fair after
all I was thinking about the nation
itself hearing katha pollitt and hearing
Marvin Miller as a butyl right for the
nation and the style of writing the
substance as well as the impulse and
they've been review of Edmund Wilson
this morning the New York Times man of
letters indeed he was is another kind of
man of letters knits Chris Hitchens you
see a man who has his own style his own
way and the world is his oyster in a
sense writes about concentration camps
or lumber camps when it comes to
environment any subject at hand and here
then Christopher Hitchens of the nation
Heys and gentlemen brothers and sisters
comrades and friends welcome to
International Workers day we should not
forget
I didn't actually put mr. Turkle up to
the Edmund Wilson suggestion at all all
possibilities on the stage Charlie was
on quite another topic but I'm glad he
did make that comparison because um it
releases me from the promise that I have
made earlier which was that I would be
both short and funny in the name of
Edmund Wilson I now cast this a pledge
aside I trust that you've both all of
you got comfortable seats and ready to
settle down no intention of being brief
felt feeling rather lugubrious in fact
as well James Boswell very long book
brilliant biography of dr. Johnson
probably the founding of modern
biography Cheers Boswell as well as
being a very good biographer and
remembered for that portrait of old Sam
that terrible old Tory a blowhard
Johnson not the first out of that name
was in addition to that a tremendous
journalist and very curious man and
observer he would go to things he would
he would was show up he showed up at the
bedside of the philosopher David Hume as
a lot of people did because they were
sure that Hume would abandon his flinty
integrity as the death watch impended
they were sure he would beg for a priest
he would ask for forgiveness and he
didn't and he kept on not doing it and
Boswell kept on pressing him I assure
you absolutely convinced you don't want
to do this and Hume said I think in
parish ibly um no I'm no more worried
about what will happen after I'm dead
and gone that I was concerned with what
occurred before I was alive when I
consider that
I can I've always considered that and
considerate still to be one of the great
statements of stoicism ever made however
however under the lash of comrades
Navasky Interpol and others I have been
forced to do porn as I was in 1949 a
little bit of Back to the Future in my
own behalf and yours comrades and the
fact is this I've caused some inquiries
to be made I've looked up some old stuff
talked some surviving relatives and the
the thing is the thing of it is on this
day 50 years ago this precise day my
parents were on their honeymoon okay you
try it and see some of you are trying
the Society of Latinas thought to me
that this would be so and I'm going to
share with you some of what I think
emerges from this matching without which
after all one would not be him my father
commander I'm a Navy brat my father my
late father commander era kitchens had
had in a way a good war his cruiser HMS
Jamaica put the last torpedo into the
Shawn Horst the flagship then of the
Nazi battle fleet in the in the narrow
seas on the day after Christmas 1940 a
better day's work than I can never claim
to have done myself but but a tough and
a tough day's work for the old man who
had throughout the 1930s consistently
supported the line of Baldwin
Chamberlain Mussolini and Franco and
have found himself you see because it's
my belief that the ironies of history
occur most pungently to those who don't
believe in them and after doing in the
shadows my father was put on the task of
running convoys to Murmansk and
Archangel at a time when the entire
coastline of northern Europe all the way
up over the hump of Norway in scand it
was completely controlled by the Nazi
machine there was no air cover for
anyone who wanted a sailor ship all the
way up and over to Murmansk
and I'd like to picture my father as he
didn't like to picture himself as
finally after all the trouble he'd taken
in the service of King and Empire acting
as a gunrunner to Stalin these are the
breaks
for him May 1st 1945 was a kind of mixed
blessing how sort of a day but it was a
day of work and I think very much needed
one for my mother representing the side
of the family that had emigrated a
little earlier from the that bit on the
German Polish Ukrainian border which had
been didn't know they knew that they
weren't hearing anything from the
relatives anymore it was exactly about
fifty years ago that they worked out
what had happened to all the members of
the family they hadn't been hearing from
and it was a very very bitter day and
day of complete silence and not in fact
a day I think on which she said anything
at all these were a couple whose lives
had been wasted really wasted in the in
the terrible waste of the opportunity at
the end of the first world were wasted
by those who had written the pact of
Versailles who devastated Eastern and
Central Europe again in the name of it
who'd plunged the world into depression
and into slump which wasted the youth of
both my parents had encouraged or been
complicit in the rise of fascism and
brought them out of slump and depression
only by means of a war economy and
another war and wasted the rest of their
youth and that was for the lucky ones
and then replaced that regime and that
that's succession of establishment
triumphs with the post-war austerity
people whose business therefore was very
felt very evident and who had no target
upon which they could direct it because
after all they had always John as they
believed loyally and decently what they
were supposed to do and had kept the
national patch of the social pact in her
in an honourable way and had been
betrayed for it that sort of moment of
bitterness and futility is I suppose
what would now be described in the New
York Times as the beginning of the
healing process
is my opinion that the healing process
in this case probably began in 1942 when
the Red Army mash to encircle the verm
act of the Kursk salient and Stalingrad
box it in and destroy it and turn it
back and break the spine of Hitler's
Reich I think that's where the healing
process began and I remember an old
Austrian friend of mine now dared Elle's
Tricia who was one of the broadcaster's
at Stalingrad he defected he joined the
other side he broadcast in German to the
advancing troops and said don't believe
your leader don't believe a word he says
to you everything he's told he was a lie
he's ruined your country he's destroyed
German and Austrian culture he's
destroyed even the the fabric of goethe
and schiller and Marx and Beethoven and
all the glories of your civilization
don't believe him and now he's led you
into a death trap and if you don't
surrender or come over to our side none
of you will escape I said and you've
been dropping leaflets on us telling us
to surrender in Stalingrad it's a
brilliantly written leaflet probably the
best I've ever read and it says we
should tell you now these leaflets of
yours turn into ash at 10,000 feet over
Stalingrad give up now turn your guns on
your officers go home don't believe them
don't believe them but it wasn't to be
will had to be fought to the very end
and so as it ended and ended in that
frigid and ghastly manner the three
episodes which I'd like to draw your
attention that are part of the history
of May 1945 in May 1945 the British
government released such Japanese
soldiers as it had under its captivity
in Saigon and in re-enlisted them out of
the British flag in order to put down
the Viet Minh government which had
established a national government in
Vietnam and under this Anglo Japanese
Imperial condominium proclaimed that it
would former holding provisional
government until the French could come
home and reclaim their rightful
territory in Indochina that was done
with the full commission of the beloved
FDR and the soon to be even more beloved
Harry
Truman I think it's an episode that
ought to be somewhat better known and
better remembered than it is think of
how much trouble we might have saved
ladies and gentlemen brothers and
sisters complaints and friends the
Vietnamese have got their long-deserved
and hard fought for independence in 1945
think of the shame also of all of those
who've been involved particularly in the
Democratic Party ever since in denying
them that right and using American blood
to shed Vietnamese but I think of the
honor face of war shame of that second
but slightly more encouraging that
happened it happens to me when I get
into a cab in Washington very often
Washington's my hometown sometimes is
that one of those old black drivers with
a hat back on his head and often a bit
of a cigar he doesn't care about the
regulations but what he can and can't do
in his cap sat well back in the seat he
hears my voice and gauges the gear when
he hears what I want to go he doesn't
say anything for a bit but I know what's
coming he says you from England I say
well about matter of fact yes I am we
didn't how you can possibly tell there's
another long pause he said I was there
once and I've had this conversation a
lot of times very often this was the
first time these guys had ever been
abroad very often it's the first time
and the last time they were went abroad
and they remember man did it rain and we
had to drink our beer before it got cold
and boy the food but they said they
remember no thing which is it was the
first time they'd ever been in a society
that wasn't segregated a white society
wasn't segregated this is a time when
German prisoners of war were given a
better time than they were and they
remember it in a way that touches me
very very much I always say the end
world was very nice of you to come over
you didn't have to do that and
appreciate it very much appreciated
George Orwell noticed a mass observation
survey at that point among British
public house owners because it was
feared that there were so many British
men overseas and the American soldiers
were so well paid and so much better
dressed that there might be animosity
towards them so they took surveys one of
the old ladies who had a pub near an
American air base was asked you had any
trouble with the Americans no no ill of
the Americans love the Yanks love them
always pleased to see them what no
trouble at all I mean
no complaints very kind no not very nice
boys always fast about drink very nice
with the girls and all that well you
absolutely sure you come great well I
will say this but J want to be quoted
sit like the Americans very much I'm not
sure I care for some of the white ones
they brought over with them all well was
George Orwell as one of the future
noticed this finding anyway in my
father's hometown of Portsmouth er never
tell there was there was a big riot the
locals all turned out of the pubs when
the when the military police came around
to try and drag the black soldiers back
from the bar to the to the segregated
camp and said leave him alone there you
know you're no better than they are and
it was a great moment in in Portsmouth
history and um it's a call me
sentimental if you will but one of the
guys was involved in all that was Medgar
Evers who is when he went back to the
United States thought I'm going to keep
my uniform and keep my medals I'm going
to stay in their face about this I don't
see why I should go back to segregated
sharecropping after all this stuff and
didn't and paid the full price for it
but we're in his debt and I like to
recall this little moment anyway and
another thing happened which is the
Hitler's chief of intelligence Reinhard
Galen a man who had run the entire Nazi
intelligence system throughout occupied
Europe for five years was hired by the
CIA to run American intelligence from
then on I don't know what you think but
what I think is that when Reinhardt
Galen was hired as head of American
intelligence from straight out of Berlin
and straight out of the occupation of
Baelor Russia and Ukraine and Latvia I
think something very bad entered the
American system that no one's really
ever been able to face up to or ask
about since something really bad that we
still haven't combed out or even
confronted and Cather mentioned the
great moment of benign Bitburger spoken
spoken in the in what gore Vidal called
the bright autumn of his senescence by
by the president but many people wanted
to say well they that was the Kimani
mouthing off you never know not
completely all they're not true at all
at the next stop on Reagan's European
tour after Bitburg was Madrid where he
made a speech in which he said I know
there's been a lot of controversy about
the United States and Spain in their
time indeed so Americans once came here
to fight in the Civil War he said but
the thing is that Reagan that they were
on the wrong side in other words a
conscious choice a conscious and
deliberate remark showing that the
sympathy for fascism
not accidental not anecdotal not a slip
of the tongue but something bread in the
Bern and I think also worth recalling
now there's three instances I gave and
believe me I could go on and don't be
sure that I won't I'm not the only are
not the only three of Trinity or trio
but I think there may be they may be I'm
going to select them anyway if only out
of consideration for you all as the
critical crucial three because they they
invite the question that is in fact
inseparable from meetings like this and
deliberations of this sort which is
which side are you on anyway we have the
civil and human rights side represented
by what was expressed by the population
of Britain despite its leadership in the
in the resistance to Nazism and the way
that they embrace people that Megara
versus guests when they had really you
know one meal a day I'd like to remember
that the origins of the Vietnam War in
other words the inheritance the
deliberate inheritance by the United
States of of British and French
colonialism the desire by Roosevelt this
ridiculous hero was praised up hill and
down dale by sentimental democrats every
time you open a paper or turn a page
these days this old crook and criminal
who wanted and devoted his life to the
inheritance of degraded European
imperialism by the United States and
made it his objective and got it in
Saigon in 1945
and simultaneously the inheritance of
fascism the ghost in the machine
taking on that that inherits inviting
these unwanted guests no part of any New
Deal into the homeland that's what you
have to remember and choose between and
choose among because the curtain was
raised on all this a lawyer earlier than
anyone thought or was told you know also
in 1945 in fact this month a great
friend of mine was released at the age
of 13 from bergen-belsen concentration
camp name is Israel shocked he's
professor of chemistry of the Hebrew
University in Jerusalem now a great man
arguably a very great man I'm glad she
has some sympathizers here founder of
the Israeli League for human and civil
rights though he wouldn't care by the
way if nobody had heard about him or
cared for
founder of the Israeli League for human
and civil rights are unbelievably
courageous and and decent person I
sometimes call him up and say how are
things going in your neck of the woods
Israel he says well I can tell you are
some encouraging signs of polarization
I like to make this one of my mottos I
like to try and start every day like I
don't about you every day I look at the
New York Times and see are they still
saying all the news that's fit to print
on the front page are they still doing
that so I okay I'm still pissed off with
them every day I also think maybe
there'll be some encouraging signs of
polarization all the same because in the
New York Times every day you find the
word consensus is always used as a plus
word unity is always used as a plus word
everything divisive very bad word
bipartisan very good parties are not so
good crashing ISM [ __ ] nonsense the
building of a false consensus and the
burying of history and the burying of
dialectic every day before you'll rise
in the name of the ideology of
objectivity who here remembers hearing
Ronald Reagan seeing him called a great
communicator in print in a news story
hands up anybody quite a few who
remembers hearing him called liar in a
news story
well that roll Reagan is a great
communicator as a value judgment that
Ronald Reagan was a liar as an objective
statement of fact that's why you read
the one in the news story and not the
other and that's the ideology of
objectivity right there for you so you
need the corrective and we may need it
we may need it sooner than we think the
stench in 1945 all across Europe
including the town in which I was
brought up Portsmouth where I could
still see it when I was a small boy the
bomb sites and the rubble in the
wreckage but not all of it because the
stench of 1945 all the way across here
was the stench of disinfectant being
sprayed on rubble you can't dig any more
there's no there's no point there's only
putrefaction and misery underneath you
can't keep digging if you don't
disinfect it now I would say that the
stench of disinfectant sprayed on rubble
the rubble is on top of human remains is
the particular tang stench odor of
fascism and we used to in our movement
in our pages and so on say we'd give the
title anti-fascist
- the older comrades to those who'd
suffered and been through it and so on
we never thought I think many of us that
how soon we might have to earn this
great title of honor for ourselves there
we were warned you remember the end of
Herbert or Brett's play our tour away
when the leader steps forward to the
front of the stage after Hitler's body
has turned to carrion after all it lasts
and says well this is the thing that
nearly had us mastered but do not think
that that is all you men for though we
rose up and we beat the bastard the
[ __ ] that bore him is on heat again and
I think the stench of rubble and carrion
and disinfectant from Oklahoma is a kind
of a warning and this time it's not
digging out at the end it's digging out
at the beginning of a battle with
reaction with the Gayler knights and
their descendants and with those who
wanted to turn our our yours my
Democratic Republic into an empire KKK
is kinder Kershaw and Cuccia to these
rebels as they call themselves these
anti-establishment figures and nothing
of the kind they say they're against the
government their learned pioneers and
frontiersman who are they
where does gordon liddy come from but he
isn't a pimp of the state an incubus
from the national security system where
is oliver north come from who dares say
this man is a rebel or dissident he's an
outgrowth of the government I know sir I
promised you nothing less
what's anti-government about these
extruded forces of the state they will
when the time comes if it does come we
should take care to discuss it so buddy
but if the time should come when push
came to shove these are the people who
would be the fry core these are the
people who would take orders these are
the people who would be the disciplined
and docile forces of a government that
would of course always regard them as
deniable and we have been warned so I'll
save much but not all of what I was
going to say say let's be let's be
prepared not to be hysterical about this
let's be let's be artistic let's be
ironic after all when Picasso was
visited in his studio in occupied Paris
by a Gestapo officer who was told to
make nice with him and there was a
canvas of a sketch of Guernica on the
wall
the Gestapo critic rocked on his heels
in front of it and said that's very good
did you do that because I said no you
did we we don't have to be crude we
don't have to be crude we don't have to
be rough but we ought to be ready to
earn the title of anti-fascist for
ourselves and we ought not to be scared
of the fighting words the alleged
fighting words of others of the of the
scum of the earth of the the fat [ __ ]
like Rush Limbaugh and the pimps and
pensioners of the state like oliver
north and gordon liddy we should rather
be getting ready with some fighting
words and some fighting gestures of our
own thank you